chloe um what was first of all
congratulations on the win but
what was it like being out there with
francis howling at the moon and
um also her winning tonight what does
that mean to you
well um the howling is for our
production sound mixer wolf who you saw
in the in memorial
um he we unfortunately lost him recently
and his name is wolf and he's the
production sound mixer both on my
previous film the writer and normal and
he's part of the family
so that howling to the moon is for a
wolf
my happiest moments nice when friend
went and i think
sometimes people might not know what she
had done out there
you know as a producer as an actress and
how much how open and vulnerable she has
been and how much she has helped me
to make this movie uh and helped out the
nomads
to feel comfortable on set and and she
really is normal and so
i'm so happy so happy she got that award
thank you our next question is from
people tv show people tv show
hey congratulations thank you
i just wanted to ask uh i guess a
two-parter
uh the historic nature of your win
second woman uh
to win best director first woman of
color to win best director
uh what's the historic nature of it mean
to you at this moment and then
have you talked or talked to her met
with kathryn bigelow
the other female director that has won
best picture and would you like to talk
and what would you guys uh you know
what'd you like to share with it
um well you know i'm extremely fortunate
to be able to do what i love for a
living and
if if this one helps more
people like me get to live their dreams
i'm so grateful for this
i have had a group dinner with katherine
once and uh definitely fangirled big
time
and uh yeah i'd love to i would love to
talk to her if you have her email
thank you next question is from inside
edition inside edition next question
hey how are you so congratulations
thank you donations talk to me about all
of this history
coming your way all at once how does it
feel i mean
you have literally smashed this glass
ceiling that we often talk about tell me
about what's coursing through your veins
right now
well you know i i i feel um i'm very
lucky i have parents have always told me
that
who you are is enough you know um
and and who i who you are is your art
you know so
so i i always try to stay true to myself
and
and i and be surrounded by really great
supportive talented people so i really
share this moment with them
you